je vous présente loulou chez mon
compagnon de route c'est mon chien c'est
mon bébé et nous vivons ensemble dans la
voiture alors voilà mon chez moi
donc c'est le bazar j'ai ma nourriture
puisqu'on ne mange que des sandwichs je
ne peux rien manger d'autre puisque je
n'ai pas de réchaud je n'ai rien pour
faire chauffer à manger et mon chien il
a ses croquettes là c'est la nourriture
pour mon chien du papier toilette ça
c'est important malgré que je vais dans
la nature mais c'est important quand
même donc là c'est
mon à chaque de vêtements que j'ai
voilà bah ce soir je vais dormir sur le
parking derrière le cimetière à scare et
demain je vais voir où est-ce que je
peux m'installer
parce que je reste pas tout le temps au
même endroit pourquoi tu changes du coup
bah parce que
c'est pour ma sécurité et la sécurité de
mon chien parce qu'on ne sait jamais sur
qui on peut tomber la nuit mon chien
dort là sur la couette voilà moi je dors
là sur le siège assise tu dors assise je
dors assise parce que je ne peux pas
baisser mon siège à cause des sacs qui
sont derrière je dors comme ça
donc j'aurais bien voulu trouver un
travail mais le matin
pour mes jambes c'est très difficile
pour quand je me lève parce que je mets
plus d'une heure à réagir avant de
pouvoir marcher pour ça je voudrais bien
avoir un toit pour pouvoir
avoir un lit m'allonger
me stabiliser
et pouvoir trouver un travail avant ma
retraite pour moi c'est pas une vie j'ai
61 ans normalement je devrais être dans
un logement comme tout le monde enfin
comme beaucoup parce qu'il y a beaucoup
de monde dans la rue mon histoire c'est
en 2021 en 2020 j'ai perdu ma maman au
mois d'avril j'ai perdu mon mari au mois
de décembre 2020 donc de décès dans la
même année
et quand mon mari est décédé je ne
pouvais plus rester dans la maison parce
qu'il est décédé dans la maison dans la
cuisine
et j'aimerais bien trop de mauvais
souvenirs et donc les petites économies
que j'avais eu avec la vente de la
maison
ils sont partis
ils ont fondu comme neige au soleil quoi
tu touchais des aides aussi je touchais
simplement le RSA et la réversion de
veuvage donc ça fait combien ça 580
euros en tout parce que j'ai rencontré
Dominique elle m'a expliqué qu'elle ne
souhaitait pas vivre sur le canapé de
ses enfants et qu'elle préférait donc
habiter dans sa voiture elle a une
situation familiale particulièrement
compliquée moi j'attends à toi
à toi pour me stabiliser et pour essayer
de retrouver un petit emploi
en attendant de toucher ma retraite je
suis en colère je suis fatigué
j'en ai marre
qu'on nous prenne pour des billes
il y a tellement de logements de vide
mais non non il y a pas de logement cela
fait maintenant plus d'un an que
Dominique a entamé les démarches pour
obtenir un appartement dans le
département du Finistère il faut en
moyenne attendre 11 mois pour obtenir un
logement social j'ai donc contacté les
bailleurs sociaux de sa région l'OPAC 29
et Finistère habitat ils ont accepté de
répondre à mes questions seulement par
écrit
[Musique]